I'm here with Isabelle Stanton, who is a PhD student at Berkeley,
and she works on theory of computation.
So what are you working on?
Lately I've been working in computational economics,
which is this exciting thing that really Berkeley focuses on,
so looking at problems that economists face
and see whether or not we can develop algorithms and ways to solve this.
So particularly the thing that I've been working on has been computational social choice.
Social choice functions are ones that aggregate people's preferences.
So think about this as a voting mechanism.
Everybody gets to say, "I prefer Candidate A to Candidate B to Candidate C,"
and then we take everyone's votes and we output some kind of winner.
And you'd really like this winner to be the one most people prefer or something.
The problem that I've been specifically looking at is that back in the 1970s
Gibbard and Satterthwaite showed that for any kind of reasonable voting mechanism
it's going to be susceptible to manipulation.
So is this like when someone doesn't vote for their preferred candidate
because they think it's going to be better for them
if they vote for sort of the more popular, less preferred candidate? >>Exactly.
So if you knew that your favorite person was the underdog
and there was no way, you might change your vote
so that way your second favorite person would be the one that's elected.
We've been specifically looking at Binary Cup voting protocols,
which are familiar to people as single elimination tournaments.
So how could someone manipulate a tournament like this?
The tournament organizer is allowed to pick the seeding of the players,
and that's the bracket, that's in each round who plays against who.
For example, I can show you over here on the computer.
Here on this slide we have actually the Women's World Cup.
The seeding is this picking of Germany versus Japan, Sweden versus Australia.
If I wanted something else to happen,
maybe I could have picked a different initial seeding here,
like maybe I have Sweden play England,
and that would end up with a different result out of the tournament.
Let's go over a simple example.
Everyone is familiar with the game rock, paper, scissors.
And in computer science we like things to be a power of 2,
so let's add in hand grenade so that way we have 4 players.
So we've got rock, paper, scissors, hand grenade.
Now we can look at 2 different tournament brackets that have different winners.
So if we have rock, hand grenade, paper, scissors,
first rock wins this match-up and then scissors wins here
and then rock wins the total bracket.
If, on the other hand, we have rock face paper and scissors face hand grenade,
then paper knocks out rock, hand grenade still wins,
and hand grenade is the final winner.
So the tournament manipulation problem is to figure out if there's a bracket
so that your favorite player wins, like this,
given information about the match outcomes.
I'm not sure if this explains how the US lost the Women's World Cup,
but we'll leave that as an open problem.